right and at this critical time for our  country following the EU referendum  result we needed strong and effective  leadership of the Labour Party I told  Jeremy Corbyn last night that I no  longer had confidence in his leadership  and he dismissed me from the Shadow  Cabinet and I want to thank him for  having given me the chance to serve our  party thank you very much I'm gonna make  a statement the Labour Party in Christ  I'm not going to make any further thing  mr. bisson would you just at least tell  us what your colleagues are thank you  okay thank you very much indeed to say  thank you very much indeed  I'm gonna yeah okay well this again will  you just tell me about Heidi Alexander  at least did you have a conversation  with her did you know she was going to  resign I know I know you have but you  understand what I'm asking  some patients are they all going to go  thank you